[Music]
good evening everybody
and grand master in residence alexander
shabalov was
thursday night lecture
and the topic today is
the king maneuvers in the middle game
so
why king maneuvers well because it's the
the least
appreciated skill
uh by a player
and
also like
what do you mean by king maneuvers in
the in the middle game we all know that
from time to time grandmaster is playing
like some mysterious moves like uh
king h1 or
king goes like to a1
that's
not what we're going to be talking today
about so we're going to talk about like
real real maneuvers when the kink will
be crossing half the board
uh
and the board will be full of pieces
okay
and we're gonna
look at the different situations some
classical games and we're gonna start
with
a game that i think was the most most
talk
game
among the grand masters for the last
three weeks like since it's been played
it's something that
well
frankly just blown my mind
i would never be able to come up with
the idea like this
and
that's the game from european team
championship
from the match uh the poland vs russia
radoslav voyatashek versus daniel dubov
so
bose extremely strong grandmaster
duboof
as you know
one of the
masterminds on magnus carlsen
preparation team for the match
um
magnus himself
attributed
him as a
um
as a source of most of his most
innovative ideas
that being played in the match uh
nipple
uh have jokingly said that yeah well
he knows that and
because of the dubai's idea he had he
had his best chances in the match like
probably talking about the second game
and the sixth game where he ended
i came close to winning the game
but nevertheless uh duboff is one of the
most
creative minds on a current chess
circuit
on
let's see
let's see it and uh
try to appreciate like what uh i think
was just like completely
idea out of this world okay
so the four knight f6
uh
the game started as a grunfeld
nothing new so far greenfield one of the
double
main opening
knight takes d5
bishop d2
uh that's a safe line uh
far from uh
main ones
but it became really popular lately for
a pretty simple reason that's extremely
extremely safe for white
so he's not winning too many games with
it but definitely
not losing any and
so bishop d2 when you're playing for the
team
that's a great choice
um
so my understanding they were bored too
right the
dude played
i'm not sure who played russian board 1
and daddy land but uh anyway so
c5
e4 that this is white's main idea behind
bishop d2
wants to play e4 and force black to take
on c3 so
that i can recapture with the bishop and
then immediately
counter the bishop on the big diagonal
bishop on g7
of course black can choose
uh
not to do that and meet e4 with knight
b6 but well then
it will be
sort of a psychological victory for for
white okay the black did not take on c3
indeed
instead
wasted two tempos to move the knight
around and so c5
e4 knight takes c3
bishop takes
takes and
bishop takes d4
so here comes the first
i would again i wouldn't call it a
surprise i think
if
anyone who played grunfeld and
ever analyzed this position
with the engine
knows that
black has a resource here
and it's not f6 or rook g8 and
that resource is e5
looks like
just losing a pawn right if y takes it
but
black initiative after
takes check oh sorry check uh just
initiative after bishop b4
is
it's pretty serious
well king e2 is out of question it's
just like
king cannot block development of his own
pieces but after bishop c3 takes takes
queen a uh a5 followed by castle short
[Music]
i mean black black's initiative was
probably more than enough to equalize
and probably more
so after e5 white simply goes back and
hopes that
his slightly better development in the
end game
might be enough to press
with just the two results in mind either
white wins or a draw bishop d6 and
another sharp move from black
bishop doesn't go to big diagonal
despite move g6 so black says okay
change my mind
yes g6 with dark squares but i don't
mind if
since i'm
trying to grab the initiative from white
and bishop b5 knight c6
knight f3 extremely logical play from
both sides
castle short of course nobody will
defend upon an e5 castle
it's all good queen e7
no by all means this position should be
slightly better for white but
and
actually it is right
so h3 f6
and white decides to take and goku and
a4 attacking pawn on c6 and here comes
the first decision
for black
and
this game
which is like pawn on c6 is under attack
which way we're going to deal with it
and
do both play
his reaction very expected again by
modern standards i mean black does not
defend a pawn like this on c6 it's just
like
um
unnecessary at this point the
bishops needs diagonals and
if white wants to take this pawn he's a
very welcome rook f will go to c8
and
i guess
black thinks that it's going to be
enough to equalize and again probably
even size the initiative
later on
so rook d1 so for the moment
well i'm sure bishop e6 was played
reasonably fast
so boytashik doesn't want to taste uh
whether or not he is against prep or not
so play 052 d1
a5
another great move like
size and space away from white and
kind of prepares for maybe bishop b4 and
c5 let's save the pawn
and if that happens
well
if only remaining pieces on the board
would be bishop e6 versus
knight on f3
well probably white will have to start
thinking about equalizing it so at this
point
where tactic takes it because well not
only it's a point
also tempo and bishop on
d6
and black defends it then i guess
white's point is a
pawn on e5
another target for the bishop and
black will not be able to
do it successfully like two tasks like a
fight for the d-file
and defend the pawn on a5
so bishop c5 again
expected in this position with nothing
else
and q and a4 no in retrospect
that
probably
incorrect if the white had to wait until
this queen is attacked to move it back
to a4
but on the other hand it's not that easy
to come up with a
reasonable
waiting move
okay so queen a4 looked
correct
but and look up to c8 rook
a2c1 and comes like a great maneuver for
black uh
yeah unfortunately i don't know about
the timeline that they were spent here
but
if what we he did next is
over the game inspiration
then uh
i'm just like speechless okay
so it needs to start with this move
bishop queen f7 otherwise it doesn't
work
so
do we attack and pawn on a2 but like
what what exactly does it i mean
white needs to play b3 of course because
well
this drops on exchange right bishop b3
so but uh
b3 looks totally
fine
correct
[Music]
so
white totally controls d7 square
so there is no bishop d7
and
yes for the moment it looks like a queen
lacks enough squares to go to in case
it's attacked but
how it can possibly be attacked there
like a d7 is under control of two pieces
so we need
something that will be supporting bishop
going to d7 right
what can it be if it's going to be a
rook if we disconnect rooks for just one
second
the a5 will be falling also there will
be pins on a c file
so i'm sure that
white tashik felt pretty safe at this
point and also like
you're playing for a team and
you're a pawn up so the question is only
whether or not you'll be able to convert
it or it's going to be a draw so a
perfect situation for
for a team tournament
okay
um
but
let's see what happened another very
important move queen b7
queen b7
again
what does it do
a mystery
so
it turned out to be a mystery for
watashi as well
and again just a safe move
taking the bishop away open up the rook
on bishop on c5
and
[Music]
white is up upon it's not that clear how
he's going to
improve his position but a couple of
ideas one of them is rook c2 and then
double the rooks on the c file
put the pressure on the bishop bishop
goes away they will
white will be trading
and i think black will have trouble
defending the pawn on a5 after that
okay
so again there's a
one little problem with the white's
position here
is that queen on a4 has no squares to go
to in case it's attacked
but
how can we make like bishop d7 work
it's hard
like if we go rook c7
okay
um
it's quite possible this is a
possibility
okay
and if oops
and a bishop d7 then simply queen c4
check
king moves and then b4
yeah and here comes the bolt out of the
blue
okay well uh like i said
um
for those of us who sold this game live
uh it was just
such a revelation
that uh
some kim table is absolutely
correct
and
you
so starting move is king of selling okay
and
my guess is
that
uh
what tashick still didn't get what this
move is for
probably
he thought that black's idea is to go g5
h5
and g4 open up the
h file and frankly
uh i must say that that's what i thought
duo is going to do
g5 h5 and g4
so white is not in a hurry
and goes rook c2
and this already uh probably um a
mistake
that put whites in a very difficult
situation i
think bishop c3
was still okay or
was it bishop d2 there was still some
move instead of rook c2 that would
help uh white out
but after rook c2
he became king island
all right
so
again
this is so against the instinct of the
you know tournament player
your king is on g8 maybe it's not 100
safe maybe the pawns in front of the
king uh
a little
uh
keep him a little bit exposed but
it's very easy to fix we just go king g7
get him away from diagonal checks and
everything but
instead we're using this king
as a
power unit we'll just go
and king e7 and all of a sudden bishop
d7 just wins material
and it's too late for white to
on to save it
that's a creativity
um
to me
it's like a yeah
i
there were times when i kind of played
the same way okay it's about probably 20
years ago and something like that
but uh
still when you recognize the like a real
art when you when you see it and this
king of salon e7
great
so
i think
magnus was grateful for the duba was on
his on his team and not on
nippo's and like
here we go king h2
no that's the only way to save the
queen
after
after bishop
bishop to d7 with queen goes to c4 yep
bishop has a discovery i'll probably
can't just take on f2
but then queen escapes and black gets
the pawn back
but
position will remain equal
so duboff says no queen is not going
anywhere i'll play bishop desaline when
i feel like doing it
and just goes g5 right now and here
whitetastic nerves
yeah they just
he blunders with the next move
position already is very unpleasant it's
it's still holdable again according to
the engine but
i think
this change the psychological change
where uh
watashi thought he is absolutely safe
and in the position was extra pawn it's
just a matter of
whether or not he'll be able to convert
it and all of a sudden he has to look
for
survival
that led to this
pretty simple blunder
it's really
that's kind of on the nippo's level in
the match yeah bishop takes a5
um
okay how about i'll give you one second
to
tell me
why bishop takes a5 loses material for
white
anyone
yeah don't
don't look for complicated tactics it's
super simple it's just like a
a
pretty unbelievable that the way tashick
was able to blunder that
bishop g6
bishop b6 no that's a g6 yeah
uh bishop b6 i'll play b4 it's uh oh
yeah and then queen defends the rogue
and it's like
it's not
not list white will be able to
bishop d7
bishop d7
is interesting but my guess on bishop d7
idea was to
do what uh
just take it right and
take
and now white has two pawns for the
exchange so i i might like uh
i know should i go
b4 or
just maybe move the bishop back to e1
uh
two pawns for uh for the rook is
no at least it's not a blunder i think
white is the one who's playing for a win
here he'll be able to go
bishop e1 and then transfer knight on d
on c4 uh it will be black who needs to
make a draw here so
it's
something different
it is a real blunder white is lost after
this move bishop takes a5
okay
take your time it's not hard but like i
want you to find it
queen h6 i'm not sure how to interpret
it h6 is this one if you saying queen a6
then same thing before
and
you cannot take on before because i'll
take back with a check
okay
okay
kim again
got us a correct answer but i think he
took it off so
if anyone saw it you're
welcome to
yep okay that's cool
this is the answer
rook takes takes and just bishop before
attacking both queen and rook
uh
which is no i don't know it's okay
it's not
you don't have to be a super grandmaster
to see this it's it's pretty obvious
continuation and the white has just lost
queen a4
takes a3 no well when you playing for
the team uh
it's psychological shock but also
you don't even at the most lost position
you don't resign right away you still
want to
play a few moves and this is what white
tasha oh actually
no here after bishop d6 he did resign
position is completely lost
it just
blocks up a piece and
better positionally
so
again i just want you to look at this
one this position and think about it
how obvious the idea of king f7 e7 looks
to you here how natural it is
just to use the king as a
yeah power we know that in the end game
it's common the king
is a strong piece
don't remember who first said it it was
a stein it's uh
or
i think it was tiny so
but uh in the middle game when we trying
to
to hide our king away from opponents
pieces
that's
a revelation it's just a great one
okay
now let's move on and uh
talk about
some of the
classical examples of the same
idea
of the king
trips in the middle game and we'll start
with the famous petrossian
unsecure
game
um
i guess i'm not sure it was olympiad or
the friendly match with the russia
versus is germany
at that point 1960 but uh
here we go no
to ground petrosian
no need to
you know introduce this guy um
against wolfgang
walgren unticker um i think
it's
i'm again i'm not sure what's the
difference uh age difference between him
and volgan ullman um
because i know ullman was the board one
for his germany for a long long time but
was unsecure older and was
bored one before woman
that i must admit i i don't remember
okay
so anyways uh
the opening
queen's gambit declined with a little
twist bishop g5 instead of knight c3
and
guess this confused black a little bit
and he plays c6
which is a little bit incorrect so he
black is trying to play slav
but the whole idea of sloth the the main
idea of sloth is that after
in this position if
white really wants to play bishop g5
then it's a gambit then it's a very
complicated gambit after d takes c4
and
after e4 there are two
it's the line called but but finnick
variation one of the most complicated
lines in
not only in
the theory of the closed openings but in
chess
so
right so here when white
did not play knight c3 and goes bishop
g5 and black plays c6 well white doesn't
have to sacrifice the pawn anymore and
he simply can go e3
and this is what or
no it
okay
if
why i cannot move it any longer let's
see
oh yeah because
it was a different
move order okay
c6 no queen c2 or e3 um
maybe e3 petrossian wasn't sure about
bishop before check right so when c2
more precise
so white
got the best of both worlds the queen's
gambit declined
and the slav so he got
he didn't sack the pawn and got the
bishop g5 already
and black c6 looks a little strange and
this is just a passive version of a
queen's gambit decline usually black
plays c5 in just one move and not in two
moves like here okay
anyway uh bishop f4
yes uh
again i i can just speak for like 15
minutes like y bishop f4 and not bishop
h4
let's just leave it at this that
this move is better in this situation so
knight d7
takes takes
um
another
you know questionable capture like why
not he takes but anyway so bishop d3 a6
castle
b5
well
by madden's by modern standards it's all
like really really strange play for
example you're not supposed to push
pawns on the site where you
uh have a
disadvantage like and space disadvantage
or like
the sort of pieces influence
disadvantage and no clearly queen site
is a
white's territory
but you know black played this
a4 b4 and knight a2 so petrossian is
already spent couple of moves to move
the knight on b3
where it can go later on on c5 or a5
98
knight b3
typical no rush
strategy
for t ground petrosian knight d6
and pretty soon we come into position uh
in question so black totally controls
the c
file a4 is protected a5 is a weak one
looks like black puts a knight on
d4 but that on c4 but it will be
exchanged
momentarily
and then rook will get back to c file
group d8
rook c6 and g6
now
so we arrive to position where black
have lacks absolutely lacks any counter
play the white dominates on the c file
however
it's not enough to win the game
to win the game
we need to improve the white position
and it's not going to be easy it's not
going to be easy thing to do
it looks like we can go rogue b6 and
king g7 and then
maybe oops
the other rook goes to
c6 and then well finally rook moves to
a6 and will will be able to
capture pawn on a5 and win the game
the problem is that once we go rook b6
once oh g6 already played rook b6 the
black will immediately go bishop c7
uh
immediately go bishop c7 and taruk
unfortunately has to go back
and position will be
repeated
okay
so
white needs a plan how is it going to
improve this and uh
win
win this game and petrossian demonstrate
like absolutely classical plan that
became a standard
uh standard for golden standard for
positions where one side doesn't have a
count to play
so
the winning plan
is
is to
believe it or not
attack the black king
okay it's hard to imagine that this is
possible
uh yeah at this point but uh
the game will be finished by white by
porn storming
on a king side
and uh it's hard to see it from here if
if
black
would
know in advance that this is going to
happen like probably would not even play
g6 it every pawn move on a king side
makes it easier for white
to
[Music]
carry on his plan
so the pawn storm on a king side will
win this game but before
the pawn storm happened right because it
will expose the white king
where should white king go
if you can write like uh it off the
board and place it on any square on the
board where do you think
the white king belongs to before the
uh gh and f pawns will go forward a2
yeah correctly i would even say b1
because well
just in case if we at any moment will be
able to take the pawn on a5 and then
black will play for example queen eight
back and knight will go back to b3 i
don't want a4 pawn to be taken with a
check so i would just say
you know
b1 is is enough
but
of course a2 is is a final destination
in case and
so let's see how petrosian does it
he goes
okay i'm a little bit into yeah
so
no g3 is a start
and king of one
will start running
king j8
h4
no
okay
a little bit committal i mean
um
i i would bring the king over to a2
first and then i'll see which one of my
pawns will go forward
but peter rosen knows that it's gonna
work anyway so h4 and maybe it also
confuses opponent a little bit because
when
we see h4 right and we'll play h5 we
think about possible g4 later on and
everything we think that white will do
it with the king still on f1
but
only around here after king e1
i believe unticker realized that what's
common to him that the king will be
relocating
all the way to b1 and then queen will
retreat back to e2
and the pawn storm will start
king c1
king gets in place
king here queen a2
queen b7
and rook c1 no okay i don't know about
this move what's for why not g4 king g7
and queen b5 check no okay the trojan
like to to do it this way okay no rush
and of course g4 is a plan but why not
just
torture your opponent that one more time
before doing that
so queen comes back
and now f4 king g7
2 queen b7
and finally
finally g4
okay
um
so the question is would f5 help
blackout
no it would not because again the
principle of two weaknesses after f5 we
got two nominal weaknesses e6 and a5 for
black
so there will be a way to win it one way
i don't know what it's going to be
is a simple knight c5 uh or maybe after
some preparation
some breakthrough in the center with e4
and g4
but
two weaknesses it should be a win
okay
actually after f5 this uh rook
relocation that i was talking about
b6 rook c6 and the rook on a6 already
uh something that white can do because
bishop c7 is no longer there
pawn on e6 is
none that's it after g4
black position disintegrates
queen e7 h5
the very straight forward
king a2 no white wants to take on g6 but
he doesn't want queen doesn't want coins
to be traded
so king goes away
king g7
takes takes
nobody's gonna trade queens
okay was a black king like this
bcp7 queen of two
now immediate threats
started to
dominate the position knight d2
um
yeah well knight f3 e5 why not
b3 no
he said that was a bad idea unsafe let's
go back
and just finish it up with the queen and
two rooks
bishop f6 rook c8
rook d7
knight c5
b3 check here rook d6 alright
what's the
winning move for white right now
rook g1 is not bad but uh
um
rook g1 okay let's see
um
no it doesn't look pretty i must admit
yeah queen has to move queen h6 check
and then roxy
um
probably
probably winning i will have to
sacrifice
my queen
yeah maybe it's rook g1 there's this
some chances yeah if i'll simply
if i'll simply take a rook and suck it
and it's no
it doesn't feel like there's a lot of
chances but uh
not least the game would continue right
um
f5 was correctly pointed out right
d8 rook is pm so if queen takes on d6
that so is this shot with f5
white target is the queen and the rook
on d6 so position is lost
this check doesn't change anything
because
well knight d7 is still there
in case of being taken and that's where
unsecured resides
okay
uh
it's just you know another
amazing
strategic masterpiece by
t grant petrosian
like the whole idea it became a standard
middle game plan after this one so
when one side just dominates an open
file the other side has no account to
play
the way we improve the position is on
king's safety we're adding applause to
us on the king's safety
and that means the one storm and if our
king
happens to be on the site where the pawn
storm will take place
we simply evacuated to the other side
just nothing complicated but
again it only became uh
a standard plan after a game like this
so
all right so
we'll can go on
bottleneck or storage uh
belgrade 1960
nine the predrug of storage one of the
top
yugoslavian grand masters around that
time and
yugoslavia used to be at a
powerhouse chess powerhouse after
world war ii
and
a lot of big names came out of this so
again let's go to position and question
king's indian
knight d7 is something that modern
theory condense
it's no longer a way for black to
equalize here
because
white's development is still unhindered
here like
c6 h3 i i just don't want to comment on
this moves they are
like have nothing to do with our
uh topic today
bishop f2 a6 so black is waiting
obviously waiting for white
to show him which way he's going to
castle
before pushing points with g5 and h5
because
uh what's the point to do this if white
simply castles long and go can be one so
all storage is waiting a6
all right if
white allows b5
that means he will have to
probably will have to castle short
and then g5 h5 plan it will be so
buttoning tries to stop it
okay
after you say i can wait i i'll after a4
now if you cast a long then i'll play b5
i'll sacrifice the pawn but i'll open a5
okay
b4 so it looks like bot winning saying
i'm not really
going to be castling long after a4 and
b4
no okay black says
castle short be my guest i mean i like
need to know what's going on
not yet so a5 and let's see
what's your decision about
b6 pawn is going to be you're going to
be taking on a5 and give me the b file
or
not
so
bishop f6
was surprisingly a correct decision i
think it came without like a real
understanding
from a storage part like what did he was
doing he just you know his hand made the
correct move was good
and
here comes like a real real deep
psychological move from white which is a
it's a
pleasure not only to see but to explain
what's going on okay
so
white doesn't want to castle short
because then g5 h5 g4 plan will be in
place and
maybe it would not work maybe it would
work but that clearly black has
something to do
if we cannot castle long right now
because the position on the queen side
is not yet i mean
pawn chain is not fixed yet
while black will take on a5 and open the
b file
so
look at this move
okay
rook a2
so botanic just waits because he doesn't
really understand what the
the last move bishop f6
is his opponent knows what he's doing or
he would just got lucky
rook a2
um
for
a normal player it's the move that's
impossible to explain like what is a
white tries to do like double on a file
no it's like a rook still on h1
it's the perfect perfect waiting move
and if black knew what's coming
he would also wait he would play i don't
know whatever uh
bishop b7
he would do
h5 maybe king g7 that that could have
happened
but
now
with his move b5
our story shows that his previous move
was just a pure luck okay
and uh
that's it the
pawn structure on a queen side got fixed
and what it means
that that's where the white king gonna
go
okay so rook a2 had another
psychological effect on black he
probably thought that after rook moved
white cannot castle anymore
to to the queen side right cannot play
cannot play castle long
but
what black forgot about
is what we called an artificial castle
so next move for white is
key indie one
it's just like uh
it's
no again it's it since that time like
right game was played 1969 and
what it's a
50-plus years ago okay i was like two
years old at that point
um it became a standard
right the artificial castle to the fixed
side bilika or uh
yeah it became but those guys were
pioneers and
like and probably were coming up with
those concepts over the board and that
that's that's just great
so rook f7 no the rest of the game is
just
finishing up king goes to b1
bishop relocates to b3
rook c2
black has nothing else to do here has to
wait
knight to d1
then it looks like everything
set for white to play rook c6
but again
buttfenix surprises
everyone here so if i would be giving
this position uh
to seoul
okay i would probably
will look at the plans like rook c6 and
then bishop b6 and then exchanging dark
through a bishop and using dark squares
to invade with my rooks
but batwinic
once again shows that it's like the
flexibility
it's the great
great uh
uh
i know skills
by super strong grandmasters and like
yep i can probably play rook c6 and win
it but
attack on a king is always the most
effective
way to finish the game
and even though
they didn't have a reputation like a
tall and maybe spassky and uh
other players who were notoriously atta
attackers right there these two guys
were positionable but again
after knight gets to d3 and 98
he decides that instead of rook c6 he's
going to win it by direct attack on the
king
that's the once the king evacuated to
safe side
well there if there is a possibility of
the pawn storm
white will do it and comes here
and g3
and again black position is just
disintegrates very very quickly i'll
open uh remove the f pawn and then i'll
remove e5 pawn
and white space advantage will
finish the deal
white still needs to pay a little bit
attention to what's going on
and
a rook trade no longer helps black
because while position gets open
and
see how safe the white king is on b1
like because the pawn structure is fixed
check queen takes
queen e7 e5
yeah this is not even a pawn sacrifice
so
take stakes knight d7
and bishop b2
taking his time
and
how would we finish black
what's the next one
very good
h5 for this
so if it's an uh winning end game
you don't have to
go for a checkmate it's just like not
the only way to win a chess game
uh
if
end game is clearly and
winning like in this situation that's
good enough
okay
take takes takes on h5 and uh black
simply resign
another
another fantastic um
you know masterpiece
it just but
yeah this
couple of moves so
white didn't castle and he played a5 and
then he waited
and for the
peak of the whole thing it's just rook
a2
just simply showed us how how much more
like batwinic was understanding or
what's going on than his opponent there
it was pretty cool
okay and uh
let's go on
and let's
check out one of the most uh
famous
game in the
very very popular line
which is a
uh swashnikov sicilian
okay i also want to say a couple of
words to
about
the
grand master that this line was named
after so um i was i was blessed when i
was a a junior
back in the regal latvia i had access to
three coaches okay there was michael
tall
and there was a grand master bagheera
who was a coach to petrossian and polo
gayevsky
and there was also was eugenie
svechnikov so i'd like a choice of three
coaches that i was like working with and
uh the guy
past
passed away a couple months ago
unfortunately
call it well
it happened to a lot of
great people last two years and uh
well this is one of his finest
achievements so after this game
the the line really picked up this game
was published in all the magazines all
over the world and uh
you'll see okay
what black achieved in this game it was
absolutely unspeakable even though by
modern ice it's nothing out of this i
mean it's pretty uh natural it's
so e5
knight goes to b5 and d6 so starting
position for swastika variation
black absolutely gives up the d5 square
and d6 pawn is weak so sims like white
hat should have an undisputable
advantage very easily
but
black's unbelievable dynamic is a
carried uh i mean compensates for these
two weaknesses
and that's the whole idea of this
fascinating variation since this game
was one of the
starting games
in this line b5 again
it's all modern theory there's nothing
here that is
new
and after f5 uh white
a lot of moves here there you cannot say
there's one move is more common than the
other there's bishop d3
there is
there's this trap that starts with move
c3
okay that's the little trap and uh
black needs to know that he cannot take
the pawn on e4 because then
surprisingly
the problem is that the black weakened
this diagonal and the thread is
knight c7 check king d7 queen g4
checkmate
so
but yeah this position very well known
uh c3 or bishop d3 are main moves
but
oh that that was played b6
c4
queen a5 check king f1
bishop takes knight d4
and here comes like this famous uh
dynamic from the black pieces
knight c2 takes
e4
check
okay block is forced to go forward
bishop takes b5 white is up upon
but black absolutely dominates on the
dark squares the only problem is the
king
that
so swesnikov covers the seventh rank was
uh r7
check
king f6
g4
rookie 7
queen b8
the pawn on d6 is hanging
queen takes d6 is something that the
black cannot afford to to happen right
[Music]
if rook moves away where did the movie
wait he's selling while i give this
check on d8 again
so how do we defend the pawn on d6
27 rook
quincy seven with down a pawn and the
end game was uh white two pawns a and b
rolling forward
just imagine i'll put the bishop on c6
right and my both pawns will be
which is four
yeah no queen queen before the
possibility but after a3 um
roxy sound queen d8 check again it's
like kind of unpleasant actually we get
in check made it if we go rook c7
and i'll give you this check right you
cannot block it because is a rook or
queen is lost so you have to step on a g
file and then
i'll open g file and check mate here
so
problem with d6 so how we defend it yeah
and i see a lot of
a lot of people in chat and give us a
correct answer
how about this
king e5
again
nothing super special by modern
standards but
i i can assure you that in 1976
this was just like
absolutely amazing that you can do it in
a practical game
get the king on e5 when the
two rooks queen and the bishop are still
on the board
okay
and not only you'll be able to do this
you'll win the game convincingly and
after this game the pop
it was the first spike of popularity of
the of the line of this fashion of
variation the people started they
started paying attention to what's going
on before
uh everyone was so skeptical they were
like no way i mean the
d5 was too weak
uh activity is not enough
but after this game
well white played f4 already a decisive
mistake uh i think
there were better defenses but no i can
it was a psychological shock for
evanovich
uh sadashikov opponent uh he probably
thought that this is just no way it's
possible
taken yeah who cares f4 if needed i'll
go to f3
okay if that's where it's going to be
saved so queen takes d6 rookie five
here we go
suddenly all black pieces are coming to
life
uh kinky two
no okay well now we're coming back
rook f1 and just takes
so king literally leads the army
forward so before
bishop g7 the really nice uh
really nice intermediate move
if queen takes h8 uh no of course we're
going to be taking bishop with a check
first
so
black is already absolutely winning
takes takes
no the end game where black has like uh
you know
four connectors
is just like a little too much
also bishop and the rook completely
control on the pawn uh a pawn
so
yeah bishop gets on a diagonal and that
spells the end for
absolutely no rush without jeep one and
e pawn
yeah it's a
white final resign
and
it's a beautiful beautiful game
again
that's shown us
but
you know again it might seem very very
simple
by
modern standards but without this game
without the petrossian game without
between games that we saw before there
simply would not be a doubles game that
we saw the first one and
like so those club we're all standing on
the shoulders of those classics
okay and it's very important once again
to study the games of classical players
uh
and without it like
you know
we need to know our history and
this is part of a message today that uh
you guys
study classics okay find
uh those ideas and try to use it like
the dubaf does and it works for him so
it should work for you as well and
i guess
this is it for
today for our lecture
and
i'll wrap it up thanks everyone who've
been here today and well have a nice
weekend
bye
[Music]
you